Alex didn't believe that you got buried
oh you didn't no interesting
he had a whole reason for why you didn't
get buried I kind of forgot you don't
just forget yourself
this is the most viewed video You're
questioning my existence yeah exactly
I'm just saying the camera angles made
it seem as though oh I could have fixed
it I remember this whoa and I think
you're you're worth too much to take
that risk uh yeah my mom was like crying
when I filmed this video I was like Mom
I promise we did the math
um let me skip to over here to show you
there's a scene where the boys literally
dig down and yeah see that penis sign
yeah they literally dug down and put
that there yeah uh so you you could have
planned
wait wait right here
oh Carl wait wait for the cut right here
look you can literally see where they
put the sign there and how deep it is
underground or that could have just been
shot at a different time where
whoa
Carl he's on to us
okay with this video specifically okay
yeah
um well there's two I'm curious about
for the same reason
this the one where you're in the the
outdoor pool and you're under underwater
yeah the thing bro that was done like
five years ago this yeah the headache
yeah have you figured out what that was
about yeah it's because uh I was an
idiot back then and like we were pumping
air in but the CO2 or whatever the [ __ ]
you it doesn't get pumped out yeah
getting pumped out yeah so you're just
inhaling your own carbon yeah and so
then when I started getting a headache I
was like oh [ __ ] and then dioxide yeah
yeah carbon dioxide so then we like
called someone who know what they're
doing they're like yeah you're an idiot
yeah yeah okay and I just got out
immediately okay and then when you're
buried
under this is what we learned from it so
we had a pump that was pumping in air
and pumping out the old Air what was the
most catastrophic thought you had while
you were completely buried I uh tried
there was a camera at my feet three
could also talk about this too uh and I
went to like go adjust it and I couldn't
so I like literally turned around and
I'm you know not super flexible so I
literally like was going to turn and so
like I'm laying like this and as I'm
like bending I got caught like halfway
and I was like
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] I was
literally like guys if I can't get out
of this in two seconds you start digging
right the [ __ ] now because I was like
cotton is super awkward position like in
the thing and I just like I'm gonna give
it one last try and I just pushed as
hard as I could and I popped out the
other end and then I adjusted the camera
and then you had to get back exactly
because have my because it's like the
thing got Slimmer this way yeah it was
so uncomfortable on that side yeah so
then I had to do it again and I almost
got stuck again like what was going
through your head when you were watching
it
Mike
this was the first time he like panicked
during the whole situation yeah and when
he was panicked in my mind we got really
scared did you calculate how much time
it would take to excavate yeah they knew
that because uh I mean it was like they
could get me out in under five minutes
if I really needed to be I okay I
started practicing with my hand on the
tombstone
[Laughter]
this feels good it feels real good yeah
so any of these other ones up here you
think are fake no I just thought that
one I think are you counting to 100. he
set his sights on you he's about to
start [ __ ] on you well
he's like I think your [ __ ] shoes are
fake
on purpose for fake Yeezys so subreddits
would go crazy exposing me and I just
didn't care and I thought it was the
funniest thing ever that's so smart and
then I wore a fake Supreme shirt in a
video same thing Reddit just lost their
mind and I just I just love doing it the
piss him off I mean it also keeps you in
the conversation even more though no
it's just funny to like watch them
analyze the box logo and why it's not
real you also save money you don't have
to buy that's true yeah I'm still
terrified about this buried alive dude
I'm I'm severely claustrophobic wow oh
yeah severely so the nights before I
slept in a coffin in my garage to like
oh you get used here yeah yeah this was
in his emo phase too so you put a little
effort in so there's just this coffin in
my cold ass garage and I just lay in it
close it chill there for a couple hours
do you like consult with people about
this first that one David Blaine yeah
interesting because he did a week so I I
was gonna do 24 hours bear alive and
then I called David and I was like I'm
gonna bury myself for 24 hours and he's
like that's it and then I said all right
I'm doing it for 50 hours and that's why
it's 50 hours instead of 24. yeah but
did you see his dumbass balloon thing
who is he to judge I mean that's that's
pretty cool
oh he just flew in a balloon it was like
upper he held on to balloons flew up and
then popped him came down yeah it was
pretty cool but yeah that's so I I had
to double it because he just basically
Shadow my entire existence I mean we
would have been fine if you did 24 hours
just the Buried Alive thing like what is
the the oxygen tank malfunctioned I
couldn't handle being stuck in an
elevator for 24 seconds there's enough
oxygen in there for five minutes yeah I
guess you're right we had so we buried
that cop in like five separate times we
had you know David Blaine Consulting a
bunch of other people Consulting I was
probably safer under there than I was
above ground
I think that's what they told me yeah
yeah I don't know if that's true and
then until they start the dirt on the
glass and you realize it's like this
much glass between you and just
thousands of pounds of dirt then it's
like well [ __ ] oh yeah that's right if
it eats a little bit of a crack did you
hear any weird sounds to terrify sure I
heard tons of stuff oh but we tried to
keep it upbeat and not like I was super
scared so like in the video I don't
think we really put that kind of stuff
did that help you get less scared
knowing so many people are watching if
you get scared it's kind of embarrassing
whatever so that kind of blocks out that
no that whole time I was just like for
the love of God don't crack like because
all I did was stare up at that dirt and
so I just saw six thousand ten thousand
whatever a thousand pounds of dirt the
whole time for like 50 hours straight
and it hurts like [ __ ] like the bottom
is just wood so you're just like that in
of itself is a challenge just like
laying on wood
it was it wasn't fun but you know 194
million views not that bad I would do it
again yeah huge thank you to Surf shark
for sponsoring this clip make sure you
check out their modern and secure VPN at
surfshark.deal slash Schultz and when
you use the code Schultz you're gonna
get 83 off a two-year plan and three
extra months for free